and blue is gonna be an ultimate hero
once more I feel like water
I feel like blue is gonna die just seems
like it's headed that path who didn't
die the first one I think blue is gonna
sacrifice himself for a comeback happy
hump day reject nation time to watch
Chris Pratt make the most money this
year out of everyone the final trailer
supposedly for this was two months away
for Jurassic world falling Kingdom a
little bit of a sore throat right now I
want to say thank you to everyone who
has been following us over at our
patreon page and becoming a patron oject
people over there we do weekly Q&A so we
take a question from a patron to a
full-length video response to it as well
as we do full-length TV show reactions
over there over there I personally cover
attack I'll tie it in the flash Jon he
covers Riverdale Marvel's Runaways
Atlanta DG and together we cover my hero
academia black lightning Jessica Jones
season 2 and we also cover a lot of
music videos was most the time we cube
music video on YouTube they get blocked
a lot of them are over here on our
patreon would love to have you become a
patron eject today people because we are
so thankful to everyone over there
he's right yeah right she is the last of
her kind
you'll never catch her we thought you
might know someone who could help blue
you know come with me
you know you can't stay here oh no oh
man this personal no the hackers can
follow orders you never saw me Malia is
a trained predator might be boys
oh [ __ ] I said we shut this whole thing
down okay
[Music]
yeah remember you're the one who made me
come here
welcome to Jurassic world hey John I
miss something sure I I have less of an
idea what this movie is gonna feel like
now that I did before like a really odd
medley to me and maybe that's mean this
feels more like it's kind of harken back
to of a horror monster movie I think now
that we've seen with like three trailers
for this movie it seems like all that
Island stuff is probably gonna happen
very early on in the movie that seems
like it's either all of act 1 or just
the first half it seems like the
majority of the major thrills are gonna
be taking place after they get off the
island I get blue and then they start
creating this other hybrid like
Velociraptor which which makes sense
because they they saw that they can
control raptors in Jurassic world so I
don't think it's too far-fetched from
the new kind of world they have
established to go OK I can see why they
tried again because they at least
thought they could control the Raptors I
guess the more of these movies that we
get the more I'm like let logic do
everything that's coming to them because
like especially since they establish the
Jurassic world 1 that this is in the
Jurassic Park universe like y'all are
stupid this is never gonna work it never
worked the thing is I'm also flashing
back to the lost world too because
you've got this King Kong scenario where
it's like we're gonna get some of the
dinosaurs bring them back to the
mainland cuz that always goes well I got
hints of King Kong hints of Jurassic
Park - I am constantly back and forth on
Jurassic world often times it might seem
like I have contradicting opinions I
totally get that side of like what a
bunch of freaking idiot and then I also
have that side of me that goes bad
forget about that let me
see what the movie is but I let go of
that logical side of like oh what a
bunch of idiots and I just accept what
the plot is and accept the situation at
hand I feel like I could really enjoy
the hell out of this movie because I
love the cinematography behind it
there's a variety of dinosaur thrills
there's that one shot we're like the t
it's raining and the t-rex is coming
after that one guy is hanging off the
ladder probably from a helicopter that
does look like it harkens back to like
the first Jurassic Park in a way yeah
sure and you pointed that out and I do
think that's a that's the thing I like
most about this trailer is the sort of
monster movie element this sort of
ominous and imposing presence the
dinosaurs have the way they're shooting
them like an old monster movie yeah
these you said Wolfman that's actually a
pretty good call for some of these shots
cuz I murder the lost world they have
the t-rex come back and the t-rex is
like screwed everything up ever thought
that was stupid but this one looks like
chaotic because you're seeing that
there's all kinds of dinosaur on land
like there's even then one dinosaur
where it's out of every shark movie over
there oh you you knew like if anything
happened that one was gonna be fine from
the gang yeah like they even kept that
one near the big body of water but the
way the cinematography is kind of has
his old-school Universal horror movie
like that's why I said Wolfman yeah it
has such a dark aesthetic to the way
it's lit that it feels like a horror
movie at one point I could have sworn I
saw the indominus skeleton and then I
finally found the shot it's a 1:32 that
make sense because the one on Iran the
name that dies or the water dinosaur
pool yeah do I think it's stupid that
they would think they would do another
shot like yeah I do think it's kind of
dumb but there are a bunch of corporate
idiots and that's the characters are
beyond maybe this is just my own bias I
feel like only the first Jurassic Park
movie kind of is able to do what it
wants to do and be unencumbered by all
this other junk because it's just such a
costly bad idea I completely get where
you're coming from the other part of me
is well if we're gonna get another
drastic world movie I'll just accept
this yeah the other thing for me
personally is I don't know what I want
from it is at all I'm getting a whole
lot of ideas pitched at me in this
trailer like someone ever cool
some of them are a little like but
honestly Chris Pratt and Bryce Dallas
Howard look like they're probably gonna
give a better performance this time
around Jeff Goldblum saying Jurassic
world like it's kind of cheesy but
you're the person who would tell us that
yes all right guys well you can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell to get notified
every time one of our vids is up and
make sure to check us out on patreon
full-length TV show reactions cookie
when A's love to have you
you